bonsoir je suis anthropologue du droit
un des derniers mohicans dans cette
science des coutumes des règles non
écrites qui régissent nos comportements
mon premier terrain d'exploration a été
effectivement la médiation des 96 et
j'ai pu observer que les relations qui
durent le plus longtemps
effectivement ne sont pas celles où l'on
sent gueule le moins mais celle hall on
s'engueule
le mieux est effectivement vous avez
remarqué que les gens ne font pas
toujours ce que l'on voudrait qu'il
fasse d'où cette question existentielle
sans en arriver au conflit comment faire
en sorte que les choses soient faites
comment faire en sorte que les choses
soient faites
quand je pose cette question dans les
entreprises en temps il faut partager le
sens il faut bien expliquer il faut
savoir communiquer et quand je rentre
chez moi le soir je teste tout ce que
j'ai entendu de la journée sur mes
quatre enfants avec plus ou moins de
succès les enfants venaient mettre la
table pour notre cuvée f qualité de vie
familiale je vous invite à vous dépêcher
un et en général ça marche pas terrible
ça marche pas terrible du coup j'ai le
niveau d'adrénaline qui montrent un
accélération du rythme cardiaque
dilatation des pupilles des branches et
du coup j'ai la vieille règle vous savez
je compte jusqu'à 3 qui revient assez
vite
ok je me suis mal fait comprendre alors
maintenant je compte jusqu'à 3 6 à 3 à
la table n'est pas mise vient vous
chercher dans vos chambres espèce de
chéri d'amour
ce qui m'amène à dire que pour faire en
sorte que les choses soient faites
le premier registre le premier des
quatre registres décisionnel que nous
allons explorer c'est le pouvoir
entendu au sens du rapport de force
l'usagé du pouvoir consiste tout
simplement à prendre une décision
unilatéralement et à l'imposer à
d'autres assez grisant
il existe évidemment différentes sources
de pouvoir et le rapport du faible au
fort peu complètement s'inverser car le
plus dangereux en définitive c'est
souvent celui qui n'a rien à perdre
pour l'instant j'ai encore le dessus
physiquement sur les enfants mais ils
ont repéré mon talon d'achille
j'ai peu de temps libre ils en ont
beaucoup et ils peuvent par exemple me
ruiner complètement une soirée en
puisant quelques tactiques déloyales de
leur sac à malices par exemple quand je
me rends dans leur chambre après avoir
compté jusqu'à 3 j'ai le droit à la
victimisation
c'est toujours moi j'ai le droit à la
pression du temps à temps j'ai bossé
fini à tanger pas défini un temps j'ai
presque fini et j'ai eu droit aussi
j'ai eu droit aussi à la culpabilisation
comme mon fils aîné alors qu'il n'avait
que neuf ans ma m'a fait passer pour un
criminel de guerre
écoute pas les châtiments corporels sont
interdits dans un tiers des 47 états
membres du conseil de l'europe
est-ce que je dois en arriver à appeler
le 119 allô enfance en danger
j'en ai longuement parlé avec ma femme
qui est psychiatre et elle m'a dit les
enfants ont besoin qu'on leur précise
les règles
il teste pour connaître des limites et
la joute un enfant sans cadre c'est un
psychopathe en devenir
merci lui dis-je et donc me voilà rendus
au deuxième registre décisionnel à
savoir préciser les règles du jeu j'ai
d'abord donc un planning qui permet de
définir les droits et les obligations de
chacun le lundi c'est toi le mardi c'est
toi le mercredi c'est toi et là j'ai mon
cas l'équipe dit c'est pas juste comme
ça c'est pas juste c'est la règle et
puis bah oui mais je suis trop petit
pour atteindre les verts dans les
placards du coup j'ai mes vieux cours de
droit qui me reviennent en mémoire est
effectivement l'égalité en droit génère
des inéquité en fait place donc au
troisième registre décisionnel à savoir
la négociation un système de décision
conjointe et là je me sens parfaitement
à l'aise puisque je publie j'enseigne je
conseille sur la négociation depuis
trois fois son âge dès lors que
j'intègre sa contrainte
j'élabore un espace infini de solutions
permettant de satisfaire nos intérêts
respectifs déplacer les verts plusieurs
verres aux choses
mixer des équipes quelle que soit
l'issue
la règle d'or consistera à ne pas faire
de concessions sans entre partis vous le
savez en négo pas de concessions sans
contrepartie pour autant si je dis à ma
femme écoute je veux bien faire la
cuisine mais qu'est ce que tu as prévu
en échange
si je dis un enfant je veux bien aimé
mais est-ce que tu as ranger ta chambre
si je viens collègues je veut bien
t'aider mais qu'est ce que j'y gagne je
risque de me retrouver seul car il
existe bien un quatrième registre
décisionnel ou justement l'affection le
respect l'estiment ne se conditionne pas
et se refuse à répondre à l'exigence que
l'autre se conforment à nos voeux un
registre absolument fondamental où
l'idée de calcul perverti même la
relation
c'est ce que je vous propose d'appeler
le don y circulent des signes de
reconnaissance de l'entr'aide des
informations des idées
donner c'est un pari de confiance car
quand je donne je ne sais pas qui me
rendre à cambrin ceux qu'on prendra ni
même si on prendra pour autant que ça
marche
les choses se font presque naturellement
sans même qu'il y ait besoin de se
mettre d'accord le soir la table est
dressée spontanément par les enfants et
ils le font volontiers je vous propose
de rassembler ces quatre registres
décisionnel dans ce schéma dénommé
l'échelle décisionnel et pour aborder le
quatrième registre du don il nous faut
nous référer à marcel mauss fondateur de
l'ethnologie scientifique française
marcel mauss dans son essai sur le don
mondialement célèbre et écrit en 1925
que dans toute société les rapports
sociaux ne repose pas sur le marché
sur le contrat sur le troc mais sur le
dos
ces recherches ont donné naissance aux
mots ce mouvement anti utilitariste en
sciences sociales dirigé par alain
caillé professeur de sociologie
et pour faire en sorte que les choses
soient faites selon le registre du don
il nous faut suivre une valse à quatre
temps que nous allons explorer demandé
donner recevoir rendre comme l'a dit
cécile je vais à chacun de ses quatre
temps images et les erreurs à éviter
au travers de huit dinosaures qui bloque
ou détruisent la circulation des dons
commençons par la demande
un des moments les plus délicats
pourtant combien de temps au passé vos
parents nos parents à nous apprendre le
mot magique celle de plein fouet
à défaut on se rapproche du tyrannosaure
rex ne sachant pas demandé il exige un
mari parquet reflète contemporaine de
moss intervient sur une grève de mineurs
anglais extrêmement dure et un délégué
du personnel lui explique alors d'accord
pour travailler avec quelqu'un ce qui
est désagréable c'est de sentir trop
nettement que vous travaillez sous
quelqu'un finalement ce n'est pas de
faire ce qui nous est demandé qui est
insupportable c'est la manière dont on
nous le demande et séminaires se sentait
utilisés comme des objets et nous
considérer comme des semblables
deuxième écueil ne pas oser demander
or comme le dit cette expression qui ne
demandait rien n'a rien ou pas grand
chose c'est le cas du timor aux dons
le team offroad ont plutôt que dire à
son manager
j'aimerais faire un point sur mes
perspectives de carrière dit plus tôt tu
trouves pas que j'ai bien travaillé
cette année
et là il ya deux possibilités soit le
manager de bonne foi ne comprend pas
qu'il y ait une demande implicite soit
il comprend mais il a peu de marge de
manoeuvre et il est tenté de répondre
oui je trouve que tu as bien travaillé
continue comme ça c'est bien en résumé
demandé sait motiver sa demande et m
l'effort demandé donner recevoir rendre
à bord dont le 2e temps donné qu'est ce
qui se passe si l'on ne me donne pas ce
que j'ai demandé la plupart des réponses
qui me sont faites sont je suis frustré
je suis démotivé je boude
je trouve ça incroyable parce que ça ne
m'est jamais arrivé avec mes enfants
1 quand je dis non à mes fils par
exemple elle change immédiatement de
registre décisionnel et sont tout
excités d'entrer en négociation pourquoi
non et si je fais comme ça où comme ça
comme ça comme ça 98 des par jour dès
l'âge de 5 ans préparez vous mais
revenons aux faits de données sans qu'il
y ait besoin de négocier demeurent deux
erreurs
la première consiste à vouloir écraser
l'autre de sa générosité
c'est ce que nous avons appelé le méga
l'eau dont le megalodon une manager
décida ainsi d'inviter toute son équipe
à la cafétaria le matin son arrivée le
lendemain rebelote
et cette fois cette année mans il y à un
collègue qui propose de régler la
facture
mais elle réplique à sur un ton hautain
non c'est bon c'est pour moi aujourd'hui
toute son équipe arrivent en retard
où se cache un pot éviter ce cérémonial
vécu comme une aliénation
la deuxième erreur consiste à ne pas
donner tout à fait à vouloir retenir
c'est le cas de l'arpa dont vous l'aurez
compris il est avare de ses doux c'est
le cas du manager qui ne dit jamais je
vous donne mais je vous prête ce dossier
car c'est son client c'est son projet
c'est son bébé
l'arpa dont ne se sont pas valorisées
par le fait de manager mais par le fait
de montrer qu'il sait tout faire et à
davantage à faire que les autres
alors on résumer de données c'est le
faire pleinement et à bonne escient
troisième temps de la valse recevoir
demandé donner recevoir rendre
recevoir c'est accepter d'être en dette
être en dette c'est accepter d'être en
lien et rien n'est moins simple
le premier danger consiste justement à
vouloir refuser le ton tél l'australie
dont lors d'un dîner d'affaires par
exemple à hong kong
vous avez un serveur qui met la main
dans un tiroir en ressort un serpent
vivant
ainsi ce dernier mélange son sens et sa
bile avec de l'alcool de riz l'os
l'australie dont rétorqua dégoûté c'est
bon là moi je me suis déjà tapé 16
heures de vol alors ce sera un beau boon
et holly vous je veux pas savoir ce que
vous allez manger on se retrouve à
demain demain à 9 heures pour la négo
sauf que sans ces échanges informels
jamais ils n'ont construit la confiance
et jamais ils n'ont pu réellement
négocier deuxième travers le fait de ne
pas reconnaître le dos le fait de ne pas
dire merci qui est le mot le plus
important dans le management c'est le
cas de la hypo fo dont l'ipod dont vous
l'aurez reconnu high poe ou au potentiel
grandi dans une équipe dont il s'arroge
souvent les succès sans fin pour
rebondir ailleurs pour redéployer ses
ailes vers d'autres cieux sans avoir le
temps ni même se soucier de reconnaître
sa dette ce qui laisse un goût
extrêmement amer pour ce qui reste quand
recevoir sans rendre et davantage
valorisé que donner sans recevoir en
retour
en résumé recevoir c'est accepter d'être
redevables et manifesté sa gratitude
derniers temps demandé donner recevoir
rendre rendre
il nous reste deux dinosaures et non des
moindres le premier c'est lent kg dont
langue kg de l'an kg dont qui confondent
on est négociations vous connaissez la
série bref il y a un épisode qui
s'appelle j'ai un pote à conditions
générales c'est exactement ça 1 c'est à
dire qu' il ne dit jamais non
mais il demande des contreparties
systématique à ses contres dont avec un
tic de langage
je veut bien t'aider enfin je veut bien
t'aider mais je viens t d si et
finalement il le fait vraiment jamais
tout à fait car il tient une
comptabilité stricte de ce qui transite
dans la relation l'alternance des dons
et des contres dont on peut au contraire
s'accélérer quand ça fonctionne au point
de ne plus savoir distinguer qui est
débiteur qui est créditeur je vous ai
dit avec quatre enfants j'ai pas le
choix
1 je donne je donne je donne ma femme de
john bolton et une fois les enfants
couchés on s'affale sur les canapés en
disant qu'est ce qu'on sait tornay c'est
ce que jacques caude doute appel
l'endettement mutuelle positif
l'endettement mutuelle positif la
confiance absolue derniers dinosaures
les cheminots dont les chinois n'ont qui
trouvent que le monde est trop injuste
alors qu'il irradie de bonté et de
générosité
le principe de réciprocité dans un
échange est une règle d'or celui qui
donne sans jamais rien recevoir en
retour risque de se voir
instrumentalisée
l'homme a tendance à mépriser l'autre à
la hauteur de ce qui se sent redevable
quand il n'a pas la capacité de rendre
dit autrement il ya un proverbe africain
qui dit quand tu es bon une fois tu es
bon tu es c'est bien mais quand tu es
bon deux fois et j'ajoute cents contre
donc tu deviens bon bon coup et on te
mange alors en résumé rendre ces données
à son tour et de bon coeur
et ce qui vaut pour une valse à deux
vont évidemment pour un collectif de
travail
que l'on songe à des footballeurs qui ne
serait pas faire des appels donnés
ballon le recevoir ou le rendre la
défaite serait naturellement au bout du
chemin il y a une certaine indécence à
rentrer dans cette sorte de grammaire
des relations humaines et avant de tout
oublier pour rester vigilant mais
spontanée je vous rappelle deux choses
premièrement pour faire en sorte que les
choses soient faites
il existe quatre registres décisionnel
le pouvoir les règles la négociation et
le ton et il importe de suivre ces
registres graduellement et dans le bon
sens deuxièmement le registre du don
suis une sorte de valse à quatre temps
demandé avec les formes donné à bon
escient recevoir avec gratitude rendre
de bon coeur les principes du don et du
contre don sont aux relations humaines
ce que l'inspiration et l'expiration
sont au souffle de la vie je vous
remercie